le père noël jerry del missier seulement
tu fais tes valises et à faire l'ol est
ce que tu as déjà vu bernard riou à
branches de la juge promener dans la rue
quand il veut il ya une arme blanche
avec un capuchon rouge
le thon rouge il bat rouge
il veut et à tête
trois coins
3 eyes et la tête où il habite le père
noël le siège dans le ski est sur un
nuage
le châtel et très froid à bouhlal il est
marié au avec qui en 40
comment il s'appelle
elle est jeune ou les vieilles sa femme
en bon
et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait pendant qu'ils
distribuent les jouer
dommage ce qu'ils mangent des choix
auxquels à soupe de la balade les
fromages et un gâteau deux frères mais
comment il va faire pour venir du ciel
jusqu'à chez toi vélo à travers un
camouflage
avec un balai ben je prends de
charrettes ou un traîneau ou alors
qu'une petite voiture où il ya des
ficelles des oiseaux que le trend est
bas pour qu'ils voient qu'il n'a pas
t'arracher est belle de modèle ou à vous
de le monter sur son dos et qui défilent
tour aller pour qui les jouets et les
patrons aux familles nombreuses ou la
loi nous il est fatigué pour ferrer mais
il veut défendre quand même pour aller
porter celle en face les jouets qu'ils
apportent où il les a trouvés
photo éric à sa maison
les acheter en magasin une fois qu'il a
terminée distribuer les jouets qu'ils
veulent et d'impôts film et j'ai dû
freiner et voit pas trop femme élève il
veut il repart même montée qui voit des
poulets jouer et qui trouve que l'on est
pluie est venue chercher au point 10 me
et puis on n'a pas toujours
[Musique]